[Music]
i could feel myself starting to sweat
and a pit forming at the base of my
stomach
sure signs i was nervous
kind of like right now
i was 22 years old and i had was sitting
in my first ever apartment
all by myself
staring at my computer screen in the
dark i was about to send my entire life
savings to something called vanguard
i had just graduated from college with
an economics degree and i knew investing
was important but i had no idea how to
start
i must have spent hours doom scrolling
on vanguard's website trying to learn
all of this new vocabulary
there were etfs and mutual funds in
indices
i had so many questions
what do i invest in
how exactly does investing work
and why does it matter
i must have called vanguard's customer
success line like 10 different times
with my long list of questions
and the men who answered the phone did
their best to answer my questions about
the what and the how
but i still didn't know why i felt like
i was sending my entire life savings
into the ether
i didn't understand the investing
language i felt unconfident in my
knowledge and mostly
i felt like i didn't belong
it took calling my 90 year old grandma
before i had the nerve to open my
account
and my grandma grew up with the great
depression with very little in her life
and started investing later on
and i asked her all of the same
questions i asked the men at vanguard
and
just picturing her answering the phone
in her kitchen started to release that
knot in my stomach
she explained to me why investing
mattered
she met me patiently and seeing her
confidence made me feel confident too
she said julianne if you save and invest
as much as you can now you can live a
life of freedom
just start small
and take the first step
so i did
i opened an account in a vanguard mutual
fund and as i started to feel more
comfortable i started to participate
more
i invested in individual company stocks
i even voted at shareholder meetings and
over time
i built my investing confidence
i was reminded of my grandma's advice
three years ago when a few of my guy
friends told me to start investing in
cryptocurrency
and i felt like crypto was important but
i could feel that familiar knot forming
at the bottom of my stomach
i had so many questions how does crypto
work what is it exactly and why does it
matter
i asked my guy friends to explain it to
me but their answers felt like alphabet
soups of nfts and dows and btcs
i joined a few online forums to try to
get my questions answered there and i
was met with either silence or outright
contempt from the male dominated groups
everything felt unfamiliar and everyone
was either anonymous or a guy
in one instance i was blocked from a
community after spending 30 minutes
trying to figure out the right person to
ask a question to
i must have asked it to the wrong person
and if it felt like i was sending my
life savings into the ether with
vanguard
in crypto i was trying to buy something
called ethereum
despite having 10 years of experience in
finance
i didn't understand the crypto language
i felt unconfident in my knowledge
and mostly
i really felt like i didn't belong
this time i couldn't call my grandma for
support but luckily my friend brooke
explained to me why crypto mattered and
brooke seeing brook feel confident made
me feel confident too
brook said julianne cryptocurrency gives
equal access to financial services to
anyone across the world
and crypto is just like any other
currency we use in our day-to-day life
except crypto uses a network of
computers called the blockchain and not
banks to verify track and manage
transactions
so just like my grandma's advice i
started small
i opened a crypto account i purchased a
few currencies and as i started to feel
more comfortable i started to
participate more
i invested in currencies where i could
vote on future projects and
over time
i built my crypto confidence
i've now worked in crypto for nearly
three years and in that time i've spoken
to hundreds of women from all over the
world who want to participate in the
crypto economy
and we share a similar story daniela
from columbia says my husband works in
crypto and he tried to explain it to me
but
i couldn't catch up with all the new
words he was saying
i wanted a how-to guide for how to get
started
mira from new york says
i tried to join online communities but
everyone just assumes you're a guy
i would join and people would say hey
bro
let me just say
if you are a woman and you have tried to
get started in crypto and maybe you felt
like you didn't belong
it's not you
it's crypto
today just 15 of investors in bitcoin
the most popular global cryptocurrency
are women
and many crypto companies report 90 or
more of their users or men
the language we hear the products we use
the communities we see
reflect current users
today mostly men
and women want to participate in the
crypto economy in fact a recent study
suggests globally more women are
interested in buying cryptocurrency than
they are public company stocks
and in the u.s
more women have expressed interest in
cryptocurrency than men
it turns out the world of crypto could
learn a thing or two from my grandma
because the thing that myself and
daniela and mira all had in common
a trusted friend who helped us take the
first step
who explained to us why crypto mattered
who met whom and seeing their confidence
made us feel confident too
now i can't be your grandma but i can be
your trusted friend
to design a crypto economy for women we
need to do three things
first
women need to see her we need to explain
why crypto matters
let's talk more about equal access to
financial services and use fewer
acronyms
the unintended consequence of using
acronyms
we leave people behind
if you're explaining crypto to a friend
take the extra moment to spell out what
you're saying
second we need to design products and
communities with women in mind
if you're building in crypto make sure
women test your products
and if you're designing online
communities and forums consider reducing
anonymity in order to increase safety
for all of your users including and
especially women
and third
and this is mostly for my crypto curious
women in the room
take the first step
when women take the first step today
when we open a crypto account when we
buy a cryptocurrency when we use a
crypto product
we get a say in future products and
services
companies will need to start building
for us
and when crypto gets easier for women it
gets easier for all of us
the crypto economy will become more
accessible and it will be because of the
women in this room and the women around
the world and some pretty incredible men
and people everywhere who say
we want our future economy to look and
feel more like all of us
because we need all of our voices heard
in this new economy
it will take a diverse set of people
representative of our global community
to build a more equitable economy
tomorrow we will all use crypto to
access our global economy today
today all we need to do
is take my grandma's advice
and take the first step
[Applause]
[Music]